the first time I became interested in
survival I was just a little kid and I
was hearing stories about my father who
was a combat pilot in World War two and
I was realizing that for some reason he
had survived and nine of the ten men and
his crew had not survived and it started
me wondering why some people survived
and some don't
the most interesting thing once I
started studying actual cases of
survivors is that search-and-rescue
people would go out and they would find
someone dead who was in possession of
all of the equipment he needed to
survive and yet hadn't used it for some
peculiar reason conversely they would
find someone alive who they had expected
to find dead and this person would be in
possession of none of the equipment they
needed to survive and so the question
became what really was it inside these
people that caused them to survive and
that was the the driving force behind my
research was to see if we could find
something out about that
what we found out was that the people
who survived the best have certain
particular qualities for example they
tend to be the ones who get the
information about where they're going so
they know something about what they're
doing it's not a weekend warrior who
just happens onto the ski slope or onto
the ocean these are people who like to
be prepared
they're people also who tend to be very
persistent in what they do they tend to
be organized and be able to calm
themselves in an extreme situation once
they're calm they're able to formulate a
plan they're able to organize things
logically and take steps to to help
themselves interestingly enough these
people are also very socially connected
I've talked to a lot of survivors who
said that at the moment of truth they
said to themselves you know I have to
get back to see my son or I couldn't do
this to my wife if I died it would be
horrible for her they always had some
social connection back to the real world
in other words they had a motivation to
get there so this was a very important
key and in the book deep survival I go
through sort of 12 traits of good
survivors that that I go into a lot more
depth with but these are the types of
things that we found generally